i know some quarterbacks that uh like to
get that first hit out of the way in the
preseason game
is there any thought at all to uh taking
the red jersey off from daniel at some
point
before uh september 14th you know we've
talked about it i mean with quarterbacks
you want to go ahead and be calculating
how you start banging them around
i don't think we're going to throw him
in any you know you know
royal rumbles or anything like that but
you know at some point we'll pop his
pads a little bit in a controlled
environment you know maybe that's with
you know
a young guy who understands just kind of
you know hitting him a little bit but
i'm not in a hurry to go ahead and just
beat the hell out of him tom but you
know at some point we'll prepare his
body for he may take the first hand
you know on this wednesday edition of
pft live we become extra cynical about
the genesis of questions that one felt
like a plant too
now how does that how does that one just
get pulled out of thin air hey you
thinking about taking the red jersey off
the quarterback even though nobody ever
does that
uh and there's there's some play in the
joints there
chris is it really going to be live fire
right regardless it sounds like they're
going to bang around on him a little bit
they're going to
show him the consequences of the clock
running out and we've talked about
how daniel jones had so many fumbles
last year
because the clock wasn't moving as fast
as it needed to in his brain and he was
getting hit before he could get rid of
the football and the ball was popping
free
uh the this you know the broader bigger
picture here joe judge already doing
some controversial things
talking about taking the red jersey off
the quarterback
that that's that's a little bit out
there that's on the edge yeah it is
that would be risky is what that would
be i mean seriously but you know
and i don't think he's going to be
stupid here or do something like hey
guys it's a live 11 on 11 scrimmage
daniel jones is live guys you can come
around the edge and just blindside him
and crush him
no i don't think that's what he's
talking about uh you know that that
would not be good because
defensive players even though if you
told them like hey he's our quarterback
let's not crush him let's give him a
thud
you know it's there's too many moving
parts there you get pushed in the back
by an offensive tackle
sometimes the defensive lineman just
can't control their emotions
they want to beat the guy in front of
them so much and impress their coach and
they're working on techniques and maybe
they're pissed off for a play
and then you know their motor runs too
fast and you hit the quarterback and all
of a sudden
you go oh damn i heard our quarterback i
didn't mean to
so yeah controlled environment you know
that's fine i get that
have them in the pocket okay maybe in
seven on seven
and have bags hitting them or people
around them and he's gotta move and make
a throw with
do that i do think that's a real aspect
to talk about this year with the 2020
season mike i know from my own
experience
and a lot of other quarterbacks i've
known through time
man we don't get hit you don't get hit
so you become anxious about what's it
gonna feel like to get hit this year
what's it feel like gonna get hit this
year and it can kind of affect your
throwing and your mental decisions and
all those things
until you get hit a few times and then
you go oh that's not that bad i mean
julius peppers is scary and big but
i'm gonna live i'm being i'll be okay
yeah they're the great ones even need
that
so to not have that this year and to
have quarterbacks have to go into week
one
with no preseason and oh my gosh it's
live bullets right away
i think you could see some skittish
quarterback play every now and then just
because
they're not used to the chaos of the
environment yet
there is a certain irony in you talking
about getting hit by julius peppers and
other members of the carolina panthers
which
newer viewers may not be aware of
because chris almost didn't
live after an encounter with that team
maybe that wasn't the best one
yeah maybe that's not the best guy to
point out because there can be there can
be some serious consequences if you get
hit
too hard and if your team doesn't pull
you out of the game because it's obvious
that there's something
wrong to everybody except you know your
team
but uh but i see what you're saying and
i think it makes sense
you in a normal year you're out there
and even if you don't get hit
you're at risk of getting hit it's a
different mindset
in a preseason game right even if they
never
touch you yes you know i can be
yeah this is part of the risk that i
know i'm assuming as i go out here and
play my game and
and you got to get the quarterbacks
ready for that you don't want it to be
something that causes them to react
differently
to maybe think a little bit too hard
hold on to the ball a little bit too
long get rid of it a little bit too
early because they're thinking about it
so you got to find a way to bounce uh
them around a little bit and that sounds
like what joe judge is doing
he said he's not going to throw him into
a royal rumble but they are going to
find a way to maybe get his attention
and and i think that especially for a
young quarterback you have to be
thinking about that
yeah i think that's there's some logic
there yeah a young quarterback and as
you mentioned mike had a
you know a fumbling problem last year
because
you know oddly enough he could block out
the pocket to such a degree and keep his
eyes down the field that
he was almost fearless in there but that
is the one thing we need to see him work
on this year
you know he's a very good athlete
sliding around the pocket a little bit
more
get out when it's you know the first
second guy aren't open get out
run do something but you know don't just
stand there and keep patting the ball
and being fearless that way because it's
just going to lead to you getting hurt
or you know bad things happening and i
think daniel jones is smart enough to
know he's got to fix that part of his
game and i think that will be something
yeah they got to do a little bit drill
him with it hit him with pads do those
things
so we can feel it and get the ball out
of his hands and and be in some of those
tough spots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports